hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
a particularly dramatic formulation
comes up in section 72 of Pascal's
passes if we're going by brunch figs
Arrangement there are multiple ways of
arranging and numbering the various
passes but we're going to go with the
Brunswick because that's what the
translation that I'm using corresponds
to and you may be familiar with this
phrase
sometimes it's rendered as nature is
although the French is just say and they
it isn't clear that nature is the
reference of that so he says it is an
infinite sphere the center of which is
everywhere parpu in French the
circumference nowhere
and this phrase
gets used by many author years later on
you know everywhere and nowhere right
and it's sort of just to describe or
designate the paradoxicality of things
in Pascal this is coming in the middle
of a section or rather actually early on
in a section that is titled man's
disproportion which talks about the two
Infinities which is quite an important
idea as well as the human being uh
positioned between the two abysses of
the infinite and nothing and what you
know a human being is in the middle of
Nature and it comes up
in the process of this
contemplation that the reader is invited
to join in on you know let the human
being contemplate the whole of nature in
her Fuller Grand Majesty turn his
Visions from the low objects which
surround him Gaze on that brilliant
light set like an eternal lamp to
illuminate the universe let the Earth
appear a point in comparison with a vast
Circle described by the sun let him
Wonder at the fact that this vast circle
is itself a very fine point with that
described by the stars in their
revolution around the firmament but if
our view be arrested there let our
imagination pass beyond it will sooner
exhaust the power of conception than
nature that of supplying material for
conception the whole visible world is
only an imperceptible atom in the ample
bosom of nature no idea approaches it he
says we may enlarge our conceptions
beyond all image imaginable space so
we're going from sense to imagination to
our conceptions we produce only atoms in
comparison with the reality of things
and here is where he says it it's
is an infinite sphere the center of
which is everywhere the circumference
nowhere in short he continues it is the
greatest sensible Mark of the almighty
power of God that imagination loses
itself in that thought so we've got a
kind of situatedness of this this great
phrase here but it also takes on a kind
of Life of its own can we can we think
of can we conceive because we can't
truly imagine what it would be like to
have an infinite sphere the center of
which
is everywhere that means that every
single place every big or small point or
atom or complex of things
is the center of everything
and the circumference of which
is nowhere how is this even a sphere at
all then if it has no circumference that
we can point to anything that we take to
be its circumference eludes us goes
beyond us and we realize we haven't
reached the circumference so on the one
hand we have this every place is
privileged equally and important on the
other hand we never actually find the
limit
and this turns out to be a very
interesting phrase that has a long
history of its own before it even
reaches Pascal there are various sources
in that havette traces it to empedocles
and we get this in a note in in the
Brunswick Edition from uh Mademoiselle
the gourinese preface to the addition of
Montana's essays so it's already
circulating around although not among
the common people right but this
paradoxical concept has already been
formulated by the time that Pascal
incorporates it into this discussion in
the ponce's and here I'm going to do
something a little bit unusual usually
I'd like to stick just to that
particular text that I'm talking about
but as it turns out Jorge liby Borges
has an essay on this titled the fearful
sphere of Pascal and he's going to do
two important things in this one is he's
going to trace out a kind of you could
call it history of ideas in a very atom
rated form of this typically more hazian
and he's going to tell us that
xenophonase and Parmenides are both
referencing spheres so he says six
centuries before the Christian era the
raps of xenophonics weird of the homeric
verses lashed out of the poets who
attributed anthropomorphic traits to
gods and offered the Greeks a single God
a God who was an eternal sphere he also
brings up Plato saying in the Timaeus
that the sphere is the perfect object
then he talks about permanentes and he
says that permanentes uh said that the
Divine being is like the mass of a
well-rounded sphere whose force is
constant from the center in any
direction
Parmenides as Borges points out taught
in in in various places a few years
after his death and pedicles constructed
a laborious cosmogeny a stage exists and
when the particles of air water Earth
and fire make up a sphere Without End
around its Pharos which exists in its
circular Solitude so not exactly the
same thing as what Pascal is saying but
kind of getting there right and then in
the Middle Ages and then going into the
Renaissance uh Borges is going to point
out that we have interesting references
that are much closer so Alanda Lil uh
finds this formula
in the Corpus hermeticum God is an
intelligible sphere whose Center is
everywhere and whose circumference is
nowhere so very you know similar
formulation not nature but but God in
this case and then we have the Roman
under the rose a very important medieval
text the image reappears in it where
it's given as a citation from Plato and
then we find in rabble's pontagroll the
last book refers to that intellectual
sphere whose Center is everywhere and
whose circumference is nowhere and which
we call God so again we see an emphasis
on this this imminence and Transcendence
of the Divine into the Divine the
Divinity
but we don't see the universe itself
being pictured as such then Borges is
going to bring up uh Giordano Bruno and
he's going to say this uh movement to a
new way of looking at things in from the
Renaissance onward is a liberation
Bruno declares that the world is the
infinite effect of an infinite cause and
that the Divinity is close by for it is
within us even more than we ourselves
are within ourselves he searched for
words to tell men of copernican space
and on one famous page the delicaza
principio at Uno and book five he says
we can assert with certitude that the
universe is all Center or that the
center of the universe is everywhere and
the circumference nowhere so here we
have a shift away from Divinity or God
to the universe and as we move into the
modern era there's a sense of loss of
space and place within the cosmos for
the human being and Pascal you know
Borges is saying that the 17th century
writers are much more pessimistic about
about this and worried about it so
he points out something quite
interesting
we have this phrase
you know it or nature is an infinite
sphere whose Center is everywhere and
whose circumference is nowhere thus do
the words appear in the brunch fig text
but in the critical Edition published by
torner which reproduces the crust out
words and variations of the manuscript
reveals that Pascal started to write the
word
right fearful frightful it fear inducing
so it would become a fearful sphere
whose Center is everywhere and whose
circumference is nowhere why should it
be fearful why should it be inducing
that sentiment or emotion in us well if
we look at the rest of the passage 72
which is quite long we see that there's
a couple other places
where we get to
flush this idea out he tells us at one
point we naturally believe ourselves far
more capable of reaching the center of
things than of embracing their
circumference the visible extent of the
world visibly exceeds us but as we
exceed little things we think ourselves
more capable of knowing them
and we need no less capacity for
attaining the nothing than the all
infinite capacity is required for both
right and we mistakenly think ourselves
capable of reaching the genuine Center
of things why can't we reach it because
every place is the center if if this is
correct right
so we're not going to reach the
circumference which is nowhere
but we've almost got too many centers
none of which turn out to be the single
Center so that's one important one now
in this particular translation there is
a reference as well to sphere again but
it's not actually there in the French
it's milieu right but but what he's
saying here does modify this statement
he tells us that
we can't actually grasp extremes they
escape us or we them this is our true
State this is what makes us incapable of
certain knowledge and absolute ignorance
we sail within a vast sphere I mean you
vast
right so we could also say great space
or gigantic space as well ever drifting
in uncertainty we never really attain
complete certainty right driven from end
to end he says when we think to attach
ourselves to any point and fasten to it
it wavers and leaves us and if we follow
it it eludes our graphs slips past us
and vanishes forever nothing stays for
us this is our natural condition and yet
most contrary to our inclination we burn
with desire to find Solid Ground and an
ultimate sure Foundation whereupon to
build a tower reaching to the infinite
but our whole groundwork cracks and the
Earth opens to abysses and He suggests
that a lesson let us therefore not look
for certainty and stability right
instead let us try to make our way as
best as we can done because we are
within this infinite sphere we can't
actually get to the center because it's
everywhere right and we can never
actually get to the limits the
circumference we can't take it all in we
can't do so through senses we can't do
through so imagination we can't do do
that even through our intellect
so we have to resign ourselves in a
certain way and we can close bringing up
this fearfulness this frightfulness of
the infinite spheres there is another
place a very short passage another
luminary lapidary saying that I think
many people might have heard from Pascal
the Eternal Silence of these infinite
spaces frightens me and what is the word
there
fills me with fear terrifies me the same
thing that
was scratched out as the frightful
infinite sphere
so this shows uh Pascal's response not
just to the cosmos as such
but to the modern conception of the
cosmos and to our human place or lack of
place
to many places not enough places
instability of place within it
this is a
reworking you could say of this concept
which Pascal didn't come up with
but gives a different meaning and
significance to than it had before